ما حلولي فصل الشتاء ترتفع امكانيه
الاصابه بكوفيت 19 هل الفرنسيون مستعدون
لعوده استخدام الكمامه امام المحطه في
اليوم اختلفت الاراء بين من اراد وضعها
ومن لم يرد لدي كمامه اذا لم يكن وضعها
اجباريا لن اضعها اعتقد انه يجب اعاده فرض
الكمامات الكثير من الناس يسالون في
القطارات لا احد يحترم اجراءات الوقايه
التاسعه فهي جاهزه لاعاده فرض الكمامات
قبل اعياد نهايه السنه اذا كان يتوجب
علينا فرد الكمامات مره اخرى سافعلها ضمن
كل الاوضاع اذا كان الامر سيصل الى ذلك
الحد منذ شهرزادت الاصابات
اليوم اي اكثر من مرتين عن بدايه 20 الاول
نوفمبر وتبقى اللقاحات موضوع عن جدليا بين
فرنسي
لم اتلقى اللقاح الى الجرعه الاولى ولا
الثانيه
بيتمكن من السفر الى الخارج لم يتلقى
الجميع لقاحاتهم بالنسبه للاشخاص الذين
تفوقوا اعمارهم الثمانين عاما لم يتلقى
الا ما يقارب 20% جرعاتهم الكامله